les aurores boréales c'est beau mais
pour être sûr de les voir faut être
Laponie ou au-delà du cercle polaire au
beau milieu de l'hiver alors comment
faire pour avoir ce spectacle depuis son
balcon à Paris bien au chaud en été la
science a peut-être une solution mais
d'abord il faut comprendre comment faire
une aurore boréale vous aurez besoin de
deux ingrédients le premier c'est une
éruption solaire des milliards de tonnes
de plasma éjectés dans l'espace à des
vitesses de plus de 8 millions de km/h
il faudra attendre 18h avant que la
terre soit touchée balayée parce qu'on
appelle un vent solaire une infinité de
particules hautement énergétique si vous
étiez un astronaute nu dans l'espace
votre ADN se ferait désintégrer le pire
étant que ces éruptions sont fréquentes
il suffit de voir le compte Twitter
Spaceweather qui le recense tous les
jours heureusement pour nous la terre
est protégée c'est justement le second
ingrédient dont on a besoin un champ
magnétique planétaire en notre centre un
noyau de fer est en mouvement constant
ça génère de l'électricité et donc un
immense champ magnétique un aimant géant
qui vient agir comme un bouclier
protecteur figurez-vous qu'il y a un
endroit sur terre ou ce champ magnétique
émerge ici dans l'hémis du Sud c'est à
partir de là qu'il voyage autour de la
terre jusqu'à un autre point de
l'hémisphère Nord où tout reconverge ces
deux points ne sont pas stables et
changent de position avec le temps c'est
grâce à eux que fonctionnent les
boussoles l'aiguille étant attiré par la
convergence au nord et c'est toujours
grâce à eux que la terre n'est pas
balayée par les vents solaires une lutte
sans merci le soleil est tellement
puissant que le chant est violemment
déformé comme vous le voyez sur cet
écran ce produit alors un phénomène
encore mal compris des scientifiques la
reconnexion magnétique il se produit du
côté plongé dans la nuit sur terre le
plasma solaire va être aspiré en
direction des pôles jusqu'au point de
convergence sur le chemin il entre en
contact avec les atomes de gaz dans la
haute atmosphère qui se voit bombarder
de particules très énergétiques et un
peu comme dans une lampe halogène étant
surexcité il produisent de la lumière un
ciné une aurore boréale dessinant le
chemin pris par toute cette énergie
meurtrière pourquoi est-elle verte ah ça
c'est pas toujours le cas il y a
d'autres couleurs et d'autres
particularités les différents types
d'aurores boréales déjà contrairement à
une idée reçue il existe aussi des
aurores boréales dans le sud les aurores
australes bon c'est plus difficile à
observer parce que le tour c'est pas
tout à fait ça par le passé on a pu
observer des aurores boréales dans des
endroits très éloignés des pôles
simplement parce que si l'éruption
solaire est trop forte tout ne peut pas
être encaissé ainsi en 1859 une aurore
boréale s'est étendue jusqu'à Honolulu
ou en 1909 jusqu'à Singapour dans des
cas plus récents on en a observé jusque
dans le sud de l'Europe ou au Texas
comme le monde cette photo de 2003
publié par la NASA vous ne le savez
peut-être pas mais il existe un indice
pour déterminer les probabilités
d'observer des aurores boréales l'indice
capé allant de 0 à 9 le zéro faut être
en Alaska le 9 en Europe et même au-delà
et ça marche aussi pour le Pôle Sud cap
et neuf visible jusqu'en Australie
troisième surprise les aurores boréales
peuvent avoir différentes couleurs elles
ne sont pas toujours vertes ça dépend de
plusieurs facteurs la composition du gaz
l'altitude la densité de l'atmosphère ou
la quantité d'énergie les aurores les
plus communes sont bien entendu les
vertes formées à partir d'oxygène entre
100 000 et 300 mille mètres d'altitude
le rose et le rouge foncé sont dû à
l'azote en dessous de 100000 mètres
d'altitude le rouge c'est encore
l'oxygène mais au-delà de 300000 mètres
enfin le bleu et le mauve c'est
l'hydrogène et l'hélium ce qui est plus
rare ça peut même se mélanger pour
donner du jaune ou même former un
véritable arc-en-ciel astral mais
attendez car là on se limite à la terre
il existe aussi des aurores réelles
extraterrestres par exemple sur Vénus
Saturne Uranus Neptune ou Jupiter
malheureusement depuis chez nous ce
spectacle n'est observable que depuis
l'infrarouge que verrions-nous sur place
il faudrait coloniser l'espace pour ça
attention quand même car les aurores
boréales sont dangereuses alors je vous
rassure tout de suite regardez des
aurores ne va pas vous donner le cancer
mais c'est pas une bonne nouvelle non
plus c'est littéralement la terre qui se
fait attaquer sur la protection du champ
magnétique l'atmosphère se ferait
emporter par le vent solaire la surface
deviendrait aride et notre ADN détruit
un peu ce qui s'est passé sur Mars les
astronautes qui s'envolent pour la lune
n'auront plus de protection terrestre il
prendront un max de radiation et seront
victimes d'un phénomène inquiétant
[Musique]
les yeux fermés cherchant le sommeil des
éclairs lumineux les arracheront amorcés
en effet les particules cosmiques
traversent leur paupières s'écrasant sur
leur nerf optique pour le cerveau c'est
comme s'il était en plein jour et
attention c'est particules peuvent aussi
corrompre les appareils électriques
comme en 2008 ou un avion Airbus A330 a
plongé deux fois sur une centaine de
mètres le problème le pilotage
automatique a été modifié à cause d'une
tempête solaire au Canada c'est le
réseau électrique antique a été mis en
panne pendant plus de 9 heures ça c'est
aussi produit pendant un speedrun de
Mario 64 ou le joueur fait un saut
normalement impossible parce que les
données du jeu ont été touchées pour nos
voisins belges c'est même des élections
qui ont été truquées par un rayon
cosmique les aurores boréales sont
certes un spectacle magnifique mais sont
le signe de quelque chose de néfaste
pour nos sociétés technologiques vous
voulez toujours en voir au-dessus de
Paris mais en attendant puisqu'on parle
de se protéger et de faire le tour du
monde laissez-moi vous présenter notre
sponsor vous l'avez deviné j'ai même pas
besoin de le dire nordvpn indispensable
pour les chasseurs d'Aurore boréales qui
sont souvent en voyage mais aussi pour
vous lors des longues univers vous
voulez peut-être regarder une série sur
Netflix ou le dernier torse sur Disney
plus mais ce n'est pas disponible dans
votre pays avec nordvpn tout est
débloqué puisqu'on inclut vous pouvez
faire croire au serveur que vous êtes
ailleurs par exemple je suis en Laponie
Netflix crois que je suis aux Etats-Unis
il y a plus de 59 pays disponibles ce
qui est indispensable pour accéder au
contenu géo bloqué il y a plein de sites
sur lesquels vous pouvez aller genre le
olé olé dans les pays comme le Qatar ou
des applications comme WhatsApp et
Facebook en Chine en plus n'envpn vous
protège en chiffre en toute votre
activité sur Internet et vous donner
personnel vous pouvez vous connecter en
toute tranquillité à des wifi public
dernière utilisation méconnue des VPN
faire des économies par exemple sur un
billet d'avion une chambre d'hôtel ou un
pack de gènes dans un jeu vidéo si vous
faites croire que vous êtes dans un pays
pauvre ça peut coûter moins cher moitié
prix parfois nordvpn est compatible
absolument partout ordinateur téléphone
tablette et puis au pire c'est satisfait
ou remboursé 30 jours pour tester si ça
vous plaît pas ça vous aura rien coûté
chez signstrat on a un super cadeau pour
vous quatre mois gratuits en prenant
l'abonnement 2 ans si vous n'avez jamais
testé ce vpn c'est l'occasion
ultime de sauter le pas le lien est dans
la description comment créer une machine
à Aurore Boréale sur terre des
scientifiques du monde entier se sont
penchés sur la question comment redonner
un champ magnétique à mars ça rendrait
la planète colonisable mais on va
utiliser ces recherches pour faire des
aurores boréales la première piste
explorée est la fabrication d'une bobine
plates géante comme vu précédemment le
champ magnétique de la Terre n'est
finalement qu'un aimant géant et ça sur
Terre on sait le faire grâce à une
bobine le problème c'est qu'il faut un
courant de 300 millions d'ampères soit
des milliers de centrales nucléaires on
en a un peu moins de 500 alors deuxième
solution utiliser la lune une des lunes
de Mars c'est Phobos qui fait le tour de
la planète en 8 heures l'idée serait
dans ioniser la surface grâce à des
centrales nucléaires en tournant la lune
va laisser derrière elle une traînée de
particules qui à force va former un tort
plasma autour de Mars donc un courant
électrique protecteur malheureusement
c'est impossible sur terre car la Lune
est trop éloignée alors troisième
solution utilisez des bombes nucléaires
pour mars il faudrait reliquéfier le
noyau un peu comme dans le film The
corps ça demanderait une énergie d'un
milliard de milliards de milliards de
joules soit 42 millions de sarbonbe en
creusant plusieurs trous jusqu'au noyau
de la planète non si on doit utiliser
des bons nucléaires pour nous aurores
boréales ça sera beaucoup plus simple
que ça il suffit d'en tirer une dans
l'espace les particules vont interagir
avec la haute atmosphère comme avec le
soleil c'est ce qui s'est passé le 9
juillet 1962 avec le test nucléaire
starfish prime ils ont fait exploser une
origine nucléaire à 400 000 mètres
d'altitude pas très loin d'Hawaï
certains hôtels ont fait le coup et
organiser des grosses soirées bombes
arc-en-ciel sur leur toit maintenant
est-ce que vous voulez vraiment faire
exploser une bombe nucléaire au-dessus
de Paris pas sûr il nous reste donc la
dernière solution faire preuve de
patience car le champ magnétique
terrestre pour une modifier
naturellement son orientation tout seul
l'épaule magnétiques ne sont en effet
pas fixes dans les ministères Nord il se
one de plus en plus du Canada pour se
diriger vers la Sibérie dans l'histoire
sans qu'on sache pourquoi le champ
magnétique s'affoler est entré en face
d'excursion il va se déplacer un peu
partout se décupler en plusieurs
endroits ça dure entre 1000 et 10000 ans
ou vous boussole deviennent
inutilisables pour info la dernière fois
que c'est arrivé c'était il y a 33000
ans et ça se reproduira alors gardez
espoir un jour peut-être en vous
réveillant le monde sera plongé dans le
chaos magnétique mais vous les aurez
vous les aurores boréales
[Musique]